[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talked about what you got you
to go to his side of musicality she's a
fascinating person do you know what I
think I need y'all's advice I kind of
briefly and I'm right no no that this is
furry sorry I'm trying to push it up for
this coming up I kind of briefly
mentioned it to you I got a letter from
jail
all right well murder you don't put it
on your um you'll give your address out
my P Emma okay doesn't peel okay yeah so
essentially in a mukbang video I talked
about a weird I don't think it's like a
conspiracy theory I do like conspiracy
theories while I'm eating but then it
was more like a tragic life event that
happened to someone do you guys know
anyone by the name of Andrews no he
lives in he yeah I guess he lives in
Chicago yes and he was known as like the
good son like the loyal son he's a
Korean American immigrant and his older
sister manipulated him into murdering
her boyfriend at the time yeah a lot of
crazy [ __ ] happen he's been in jail for
26 years I've talked about it and
somehow he found out about it and he
wrote me a letter from jail and he was
like seeing um yeah yeah essentially but
then also like they kind of want me to
help promote his case but then I feel
like kind of like I never met whose day
like his lawyer him and his closest
friends and his lawyer think that like
I'm like their golden ticket cuz he's
trying to get clemency like out of jail
yeah you're talking about it but they're
like I feel like don't you think that's
like a huge responsibility like what
what if we do like a making the making a
murder asian-style don't yeah okay
you know they reopened that case because
of that Netflix [ __ ] right so it's I
can't back up anybody that I don't know
fully that he says I really don't know
what they did yeah yeah was he what he
murdered this person I think he was like
18 how do you murder shot him by with
the gun that his older sister bought how
does he know he's like 40 and the sister
had no she's in jail
oh of course yeah she's probably in jail
cuz my oh he was 18 cuz yeah my friend's
brother when he was in his teens you
know he saw a rival gang member and then
they were taunting him so he right when
their car was parked at a stoplight
he was walking across the crosswalk and
just shot into the car and killed some
people
yeah and then he got out of prison in
his late 20s 30s or something like that
you know that's interesting they still
in jail how do you find out about your
video you probably you got like an
iPhone smuggled into him or some [ __ ]
you know they go you know they go in
there from the butthole yes someone
brings cellphones oh that that thing
stretches you know I wouldn't be
surprised if an iPhone X got in there
from a butthole no that thing stretches
yeah
you just [ __ ] wrap it with the condom
and you tie it at the end and you stick
it up there our coffin has a pat someone
down and then pulled out a 38 revolver
before and that being has jagged edges
like that's a third this is a 38
revolver it's that big yeah and it's not
like one smooth thing that you can just
pop in its like has edges as round as
well probably have like vag Allah
vaginal speculum where they kind of like
open it up for the pap smears like that
they do their ask Eagles
yeah shit's crazy people it's the shape
of an L a good as a shape
somebody came to you to say it can help
to say yeah but I feel like it's a lot
of responsibility
I am just some Lopez who just eat
something Internet so I was lucky
because you guys are yet somewhat longer
than me and I'm like what do I think I
mean for me if I got that I'll been like
I'm in like I got to do my own research
like I have to research that [ __ ] to a
high extent because I'm not trying to
take you outta jail if you were a
[ __ ] murderer bruh me too and that's
a lot a lot to ask for somebody like you
who just you know you just need food
yeah yeah I've done with Joe on this if
I don't know this [ __ ] more
likely than not I probably won't and if
I want to I would research the [ __ ] out
of it like I've never researched it
before in my entire life what do they
want you to do I mean he committed the
crime he's doing it I think you want to
get more public attention because the
more public attention that's on things
they don't get prioritize ins in the
court system it's gonna be faster
process case number 20 about the
revisiting it'll be like people who got
a lot of no you got a lot of moment it
becomes case number one oh the sister
also allegedly murdered their own mom oh
she's wild why did she just kill her a
boyfriend then I don't know she like
wanted him to take the fall or something
yeah she probably couldn't do it but she
could kill her mom easy though yeah Wow
yeah yeah I feel I feel bad for the guy
because he's he's been manipulated and
even though he did the deed yeah that
bad Becca that just sucks but if you if
he did murder someone you know like um
you took a life then you should give
your life fake yeah I've not I've never
gone in nobody ever comes to me for help
like that
how come he come I could help them well
we also offended yeah total we also
don't talk about things like this
because if he came if he came to me I
would have been like kill somebody
that's not the glue would you right back
I probably have luck in quilting [ __ ] I
would write back to a mug like y'all man
but you still kill somebody food right -
like what do I write it'll be F ool
period like was cracking foo you know
what if he's just trying to fall in love
with you we wish it lovely in you
Chinese food how do you feel about like
that honestly
you know all that Koreans are hella
Korea if I would have been better if it
was Japanese no it's even worse that's
what I mean better for us it's better
for us worse for her no I feel like
these days I get a lot more respect when
they think I'm Chinese okay Chinese me
buying everything you know so like
respect its greed yeah yeah exactly yeah
yeah so that instead of Koreans we're
like known for not lying as much these
days
oh really I like the fact that I'm
Korean though no I like it
people think we're like not unique but
they're like okay pop you know it's like
what the [ __ ] all right that's a good
thing to be known for [ __ ] take it
but you know what I'm the kimchi B yeah
Koreans are cool now yeah we're like the
cool [ __ ] [ __ ] now man all the actors
everyone on like yeah like there's a lot
of prominent Koreans now I know damn
[ __ ] is straight oh we got [ __ ] raped
and pillaged by your peoples time you
guys came up pretty hard though I know
you know you know Korean Japan are like
the number one trading partners for a
long time snacks are like yeah I mean
there might be but I just business-wise
were the number they're the number one
trading partners yeah because they're so
close there's a lot of just like Korean
people that hold on to like in the past
stuff it's cuz we didn't get a formal
apology I waiting for I also think that
it's Korean Americans because like I
when I was in Korea date I didn't feel
that at all and then there's actually a
lot of like things in Japan where they
embrace Korean culture too they love
Korean drama Korean entertainment maybe
the other way around yeah and and I just
think it's just Korean Americans that
brought over the [ __ ] from when you know
and then they just never evolved exactly
so it's like their parents that moved
here so they still have that and they
teach that to their kids you know so
there's one dude his name is Andrew
Jiang I'll say his full name cuz he's a
[ __ ] loser but Andrew Jiang this dude
he was so [ __ ] races he hated
Japanese people and it was such a [ __ ]
duty I actually developed half of the
Kim Jong Ella accent is from this guy
that I met in college
so Houston this is how you would
so like I have a girlfriend so this guy
is such a big look I mean there's so
many [ __ ] stories I have about this
guy cuz I used to just write stuff on
him for my standup cuz he was so [ __ ]
weird but the guy did not like this guy
named Daryl he was a he's like a fourth
gen like Japanese dude right doesn't
speak any Japanese whatsoever has no
idea of Korean Japanese nothing
whatsoever right so we're chilling and
we go into his dorm room and then it's
it's him and this guy young that our
roommates and then Darrell comes and he
goes so what's up what're you guys doing
right he goes get out like that he's
like whoa what's going on he goes that's
a Japanese what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you're in America man I don't like
a Japanese they're so weird i saw his
dick the first day I was in the dorm
room because he thought this [ __ ] was
career like a ginger bomb yeah so this
might be walking into the bathroom right
like I got my [ __ ] and the door back I
opened the door and this fool is
brushing teeth butt naked doing this
[ __ ] I would okay [ __ ] weird man oh
man Jiujiang dude oh god I got so many
stories about that guy man in elementary
school my friend was having like this
birthday party sleepover but I couldn't
come over because his grandma said I was
Japanese yeah I didn't know anything
about it that's when I learned about it
like when I told my parents I was like
yeah I can't go because she says that
I'm Japanese he told you that your
friend said yeah he's like I can't make
it you can't because my grandma cuz we
were kids like they don't know what that
means you know so I told my parents and
they're like yeah it's because we were
mean to them and we bullied them so they
don't like us man she was like yeah it's
cuz they're [ __ ] and we
you don't like the weird thing is like I
didn't know about that drama because my
grandpa didn't carry that type of hate
with the Japanese people like he would
show me he doesn't like could write in
Japanese yeah yeah I have some Korean
friends to where their grandparents went
to like they had to learn Japanese -
yeah we would talk together and then
they didn't bring that yeah yeah I just
think it's depending on everyone's
experience you know cuz my grandpa
didn't go to the war that full day he
got a little boat dish that went to an
island Austin yeah [ __ ] runs in your
family
how would you is genetic son that's
right
you mean with children on a [ __ ]
island off the [ __ ] coast and that's
where my oldest art was born
what's that side yeah on a banana boat
it's generational yeah what I heard that
story the funny things right when I
heard that story I was like make sense I
knew it because I wanted to because I
wanted him to tell me a story about how
he fought the Korean War but that
[ __ ] laughs he let his kind
don't he owns up to it though honest oh
he didn't like my dad told me my dad
told me that [ __ ] I just seated my
grandpa wouldn't tell me but my dad told
me guns Oh your grandpa didn't fight in
the war he left on a [ __ ] boat and
went to an island and there was like a
village of people there that just didn't
want to fight they thought the war was
done so they just chill in the village
and they stayed out there waited for
Tober and the [ __ ] floated right back
the whole village that mean that was
smart
that's the smartest thing that is smart
it's just very David so like it's in my
blood dude the Apple does not fall from
the crane tree dude yeah what sucks
about Orion my creepy Korean Pena what
sucks about the Korean War is like it's
like Koreans fighting Koreans for
European ideas and causes no like you
know North Korea was backed up by Russia
South Korea is backed up by America and
then it's like the people have to kill
each other for their ideas and that Cold
War [ __ ] you know it's so crazy just
watching North Korea and South Korea
trying to come together like that's such
a weird thing for me because like I've
always I never ever in my lifetime
expected that to happen and just
watching those two guys holding each
other's hand for [ __ ] 13 minutes but
so we I think
why friendly know you're pregnant they
transferred it up to one of these okay
held each other's head all the way back
a little bit across the line they
wouldn't let go I was like bother you
when people have highly aggressive
handshakes
yeah I feel like you're trying to pee on
me and it's not [ __ ] working yeah
like it's so just yeah like especially
girls I feel like we try to
overcompensate like if we're meeting
other woman that I like businessí then
you gotta like clinch and like break
their [ __ ] manicured fingers it's
very painful please don't - I didn't
ever get that from the girl other girls
um but that is something that's taught
like in business school you want to make
yeah you want to make eye contact and
you want a firm handshake so you take
one of these like hey how are you but
thank guys take it is that what is it
like kind of stablishing like like
you're spaced or dominant like that and
just like that you're just assertive and
you're confident body language right
yeah like like I'm ready to do business
with you you can you can count on me I'm
good mmm yeah I don't like bad huggers
either
I [ __ ] hate a limp hug I like I grew
up in a [ __ ] hugging ass family and
that's how we communicated so it's like
if I don't get hugs like a bad hug from
somebody if we first meet each other's a
little weird I understand I get that but
we know each other for years you give me
a bad hug you go [ __ ] die is hugging
normal and Korean families like that is
that something that's new I don't think
it is though I think my family my dad
was a pastor you know we grew up in a
church and my my dad was all about just
love love so they learned that when they
come here or have they been doing that
in Korea I don't I don't see a lot of
other like Korean families hug and be as
affectionate yeah I think you guys yeah
cuz like I definitely embrace people a
lot more your friend your Korean friend
Emily oh yeah yeah my my family is
called as [ __ ] there no one hugs stay
with mine but we recently started hug
they're [ __ ] called even when I hug my
dad like I don't want to see my dad now
no Paul you know music his hair and
clothes
wrinkle her [ __ ] I just did this got a
lot of volume in her hair ladies got
crazy it's like this it's like someone
tall tries to hug her she like is so
nervous but they're gonna pat down her
why do I picture your mom as like this
like old cougar that's super hot not old
but then like like she's old but then
young looking super hot like burial
burials mom does not hug but I forced
her to anyway oh really that's how my
brother is with Bart's dad it's [ __ ]
funny so in the Latin culture you hug
and then you kiss on the cheek I hate
the kids because I always go too hard
and people like I'm like scared oh now I
don't kid I do the kissing noises but I
just go cheek to cheek but what I mean
the cheek to cheek my brother sees
Bart's dad and he goes up to him and he
kisses him on the cheek and I'm like oh
and his dad gets cherry what the [ __ ]
yeah that's nice to serve the man to a
man and even the first time my dad
laughs every the first time I met Joe's
dad I'm like I can't hug them and then
he was like yeah what the [ __ ] are you
stranger don't be touching me I only
made your dad laugh once that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] tighten and he [ __ ] took that
[ __ ] back so fast he said it was in
Hawaii when we went to go eat and you
cocky and I said something I don't know
what the [ __ ] it was but he laughed
maybe it was the way your face move
maybe it was but he [ __ ] laughs and
he took it right back right what I made
eye contact with them haha you got got
you though bro I got his ass maybe had a
couple he didn't like his teeth so
you're self-conscious about his team I
love it yes maybe I think I was like
that's hilarious it threw me off man but
I got his ass dude he [ __ ] left okay
it is your dad pretty aggressive my dad
oh I didn't really grow up with him okay
he's moving back to the States oh hi dad
he walked over every video I'm on yeah
yeah because I talk about weird [ __ ] is
that weird my mom watches too but it's
like I don't keep these parents watch
all the time to cook especially Casey's
mom because she'll mention something
that I said in a video cuz I thought
like a melee if they watch our vlog
Channel all the time but then she
mentions stuff that I'll say mjk news
and I'm like my mind watches everything
she watches your channel watches of
yours last time some [ __ ] to have my mom
[ __ ] is going on there like and she'd
only does it by she didn't know your
guys names exactly except for like she
somebody remembers your name really well
everyone pull out the nickname then yeah
so she does it by facial features right
because I treat you like [ __ ] she says
your name and then she said your name
because you got it connected and then
she'll knows your name but she'll call
you small face and then like she called
alright she calls Tim a short guy wide
face she doesn't like facial feature my
video so she could tell me that she
clicked on my ads through Adsense so
that I could buy her [ __ ] now back oh
she clicks on every her mom is very
typical Korean which is a lot of like
Korean women that I saw around my mom my
mom is different though my mom's like
straight she Toledo so she uh hello
what's that all those countries country
ass [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] so my mom
wears like [ __ ] socks shoes you know
the SAS shoes the [ __ ] fanny pack she
wears the [ __ ] purple vest she don't
even [ __ ] she has like bags now is
because I bought it for her but she [ __ ]
from pulse I know she's from she's from
she's from toilet the Terlato area
that's an area oh that's like the ghetto
Kairi Korea World War II I was like a
menu on a Korean barbecue item
can I get the tow bar for - yeah like in
her area speak very informal and that's
the type of Korean that I learned
but that Korean doesn't help me in like
speaking to adults cuz it's super
[ __ ] informal I'm very rude dad my
dad so he learned hillbilly Korean
hillbilly a screen so I can curse well
in Korean very [ __ ] well your dad's
from a different place he's got I think
they kind of grew up in that countryside
area but my but he was like he's more
like Seoul area so he understands how to
speak like normally my mom used to have
like a saw to do like a country accent
but she doesn't because she started
living in Seoul and then started
changing uh before my cuz my grandpa
speaks in a country acid you know so he
would be like if you said like what is
that or like ego moko like that be like
so if you didn't have that it'll be like
TJ Boyer or ability avoplex like you
have like these weird like [ __ ] into it
like what is that what is that yeah and
so like I used to say like different
country works because I learned it from
my mom so for example kylie is like
scissor i was a casa
it causes like old-fashioned korean or i
was saying like palma Negi which is
japanese hmm
but apparently I didn't know that's
actually not what it is is young pop and
so I would say Japanese oh Allah would
teach me yes young pop down pause onion
but my mom will call it Palma Nagi and
Tom my leg is a Japanese rice oh is that
why I took them I spit some Japanese
words are in Korean language but not
everyone uses those Japanese they have
other words yeah there's like there's
like a lot like like total one right
yeah what is that like I forgot my oh
yeah you know like Caban yeah very
similar here kebab kebab
[Music]